if you knew a female who took off her
body female body parts and attached a
male body parts to them which you think
wow that's a matter which you still know
that's a woman depends on the person
right it depends how what they look like
and and sort of how they exist how about
a woman that you knew you knew her very
well he said David you and I are good
friends today I'm going to become a man
okay I'm going down to the doctor's
office there and have some male body
parts attached right which you still
think would you think that your friend
is a woman or a man I mean my reaction
would be radical empathy I would say oh
wow that's a major change like what
what's going on that's making you want
to do that and I would listen to them
yeah with empathy what would you
considered it might be a man would you
think of it as a man it what I think of
it as a man right it's a person right I
don't say yeah it's a female would you
think it's a man or woman I have no idea
amazing